هذا وقد نقلت رويترز عن مسؤولينا امريكيين
ان الولايات المتحده تستضيف في قاعده
امريكيه بالمانيا تدريبات لعسكريين
اوكرانيين على التخطيط في الحروب وذلك
لمساعدتهم على التفكير في القرارات
المقبله في ميدان المعركه قبل المرحله
التاليه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا واضاف
المسؤولون ان التدريبات التي تستمر عده
ايام تجري في منشاه للمناورات الحربيه في
قاعده للجيش الامريكي في
سبادن بالمانيا زارها رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الامريكيه الجنرال مارك ميلي
الخميس واحجم المسؤول هنا الامريكيون وفق
الوكاله عن الحديث عن سيناريوهات ساحه
المعركه المحتمله التي يختبرها العسكريون
الاوكرانيون خلال المناورات والتي تشمل
تدريبات فكريه لتقييم مسارات العمل
العسكريه المتاحه